live and see if everything's working
oh i should probably change that to you
and that's to my analytics page
let's see how this works
uh streamlabs okay i can see you
i don't see the chat which is not good
you should put that
up here
okay there is a chat also uh there we go
can
people in the chat hear me and
jay that i feel like is the important
part
aloha i think we have like a bit of a
time lag
but yeah let's see yeah there's never
gonna be a time lag
yeah for sure i like your setup man
though
well looking thanks ma'am thank you are
you using the yeti i think that's the
yeti ring
i am using the yeti but i might buy a
new one i think it's time for me to step
into the realm of
super high mic quality oh really yeah
i'm trying to
that's going to be expensive yeti but
the yeti is good for
like i feel like the yeti is just good
period like you can use the eddy forever
it is it is pretty decent i feel like
you know the yeti is like for the price
it has
it's like pretty good in that like in
the quality range
it delivers and then like if you want
something better like it's immediately
like into the thousand
bucks right plus region what are you
thinking about getting um
druid suggested a mic it's like around
the 200 dollar range it's kind of like
more of a
it's not really a usb mic but it's
something like you kind of just plug in
directly into your
your computer in a way yeah so
i'm going to research that one that's
cool um
for people in the chat we're gonna start
we can i mean we can start talking
already but like i'd say let's wait
another five minutes before we get into
it
just let people arrive oh i can tweet
that actually
though we're live we got 300 lads in
here so far i see my man silver in the
chat
oh yeah i'm gonna gonna take a look at
the chat in a second i'm just like
trying to set everything up excuse my
bad lighting my uh
my light actually i used up all the
battery
yesterday when i was streaming
i forgot to charge i didn't expect to be
live again that fast so i didn't charge
it yet
i feel that bro
someone said they're going to sell the
franchise to disney
one sec ah share
copy let's put this on twitter as well
so then yeah because i'm reading through
the sbs right now and i'm seeing some
interesting comments ryan did you see
the chopper thing
i did see the chopper thing obviously
you know i was disgusted by seeing
chopper period but
do you think you don't like him i like
the war veteran chopper a lot more than
the uh
dude that one left over looks pretty
like
i like like the shirt he's wearing he's
seen some dark days
oh my god it seems like chopper went
through hell i'm gonna go that's the
chopper i wanna see that's right
chopper traumatic i mean i mean the poor
the poor kid's been traumatized enough
but yeah i know you had
yeah okay it's like it's like he uh he
got dropped into the berserk world for
like two years
exactly okay
um yeah should we wait a bit long yeah
let's
wait a minute or two longer but then we
can slowly get into it
oh bad what do you what do you think
about the chapter now that i got you
here
um i think at first the chapter
i didn't get as hype for the chapters as
many other people did the chapter was
good in itself
right um i was really a big fan of who's
who in general but i think the viz
translation
really really made me like what happened
was with who's who i'm very interested
to see
one does who's who actually still want
to fight queen or was it just strictly a
diversion
to capture drake because i want to see
what oda's going to do with this
character
it's rare that we get characters where
their design is
you know it's in the category mode where
it's like you can't not
like who's who but it seems like the
character himself is very interesting
diving don't really know what he wants
so this is like i'm always following
like what's he
what's he about to do next you know
exactly so i enjoyed that part obviously
jack and
um jack inu and neku everyone's been
waiting for that so
that it seems like this chapter in
itself is just all about progressing
set up yeah the plot line for for wano
it's like everything is being pushed
forward finally
exactly what i really liked i talked
about that yesterday also is like that
small panel with kobe
that uh like i feel like that gave so
much better context like
it's such a small detail but like
without it it wouldn't have made as much
sense
that drake jumped over to luffy like in
that moment you know what i mean
so it's like small stuff like that okay
i think we have
oh sorry no i was gonna say i think
moments like that just go to show that
you don't need a lot
at all to kind of just explain something
because a lot of people are worried
about oh
off screens here and this is what oda
just does and i feel like
sometimes if you just drop something
very small
like that we get to complete we
understand completely what drake was
going through you don't need
explanations you just need to see kobe
you understand what drink was thinking
boom we're here we're good
it's always fun like seeing a kobe
fanboy a little so that was cool
yeah i don't know man like the last
couple of chapters have been really fun
and i like i don't get why people keep
like i mean i do get the power scaling
thing but like i feel like you know
these chapters are meant to be enjoyed
because shit's gonna go down anyway you
know what i mean so i feel like just
enjoy it and then like you can get into
it when
they actually you know when they're
actually in trouble then it's like when
we can talk about that stuff
okay i see we have actually like uh some
crazy number like 600 people so i think
we can slowly start this
uh welcome everyone so i think let's
let's get this officially started
greetings into the chat there
yeah today some spontaneous streaming
because we have some
fresh news out of the
next sbs that's gonna drop and like
since i'm usually
five years too late to cover that [ __ ] i
was like okay today
we're gonna stream um and i got with me
the wonderful
uh jd legend below me here thanks so
much for joining me
thanks for having me always a pleasure
uh talking to you and like this looks
way better than i thought like usually i
like whenever i do this stuff i'm like
expecting like some choppy quality but
this is actually
you're moving pretty smoothly here i
think so that's good
oh yeah setup looks great man yeah i'm
happy i'm happy thanks
um yeah so we're gonna get into it in a
second um i hope everything technically
is working i don't see any complaints
from the chat so that's a good
good sign thanks everyone for dropping
by
if you since you're here drop a drop a
like on the stream
because why not i guess since there's
actually people in here
and if you haven't checked out j yet
make sure
to do that i will uh i don't know i
think i haven't put your link in the
description but like i will
tweet you out or something or put it in
there later
all right check him out um you can put
your stuff into the
chat if you want sure why not why not
put it in there
actually you know what you know what
like i'm gonna put your link in the
description and then we're gonna start i
feel like that's the least i can do
one second oh you're a good man you're a
good man o'hara uh
but yeah like people will see what i'm
doing here doesn't matter
you'll be gone for a second ah let's see
well we got you
it gives me time to read more of these
uh sbs translations because right now
legend okay where are you
and then all this trolling again bro
like oh my god
oh yeah yeah bro like i swear but like
even before that okay so like obviously
what we're gonna talk about in case you
are not aware yet
um is that oda was asked about
you want to tell it quickly because i'm
quickly going to put your thing here jay
yeah because so someone asked order a
question and they're devastated will one
piece really end
in five years and it's like to make a
public statement like that it's kind of
like really upsetting the fans and oda
is just like
by ending i just mean the juiciest part
of luffy's adventure and i'm just like
are you serious bro like are you are you
telling me there's possibly more years
coming
like is it yeah is one piece really
ending in five years was that cap and
then he's like
for me i want to believe it's actually
ending in five years
exactly but i don't think it's going to
because of what he said here and he's
mentioning that this is possibly just
going to be the end
of luffy's adventure and if luffy makes
it out in one piece of wano we get a
development that will engulf the entire
world
the likes that no one's ever read before
and it's just like we're leaving we're
leaving from the luffy-centric story
into the one-piece story again and if
that happens i'm like
yeah yeah okay that sounds pretty cool
so yeah so
like basically to sum it up um and then
we can talk about it
so the question was basically someone
asked oda in the sps for the upcoming
manga volume um if he was serious when
he was talking about the five years
right um in the in the i think it was
was the interview i'm not even sure what
it was exactly
i think it was interesting yeah exactly
um and so what he basically said is like
oh no like the five years actually
referred to the
current storyline about luffy becoming
pirate king
and then after that there will be this
enormous war that he's planning right
so basically he like he's been trolling
again
it's like five years till basically we
find the one piece and
luffy will be pirate king and then
shit's gonna go down but like oda counts
it as something separate
it's like the way i would interpret that
how do you see it
it's hard it's hard for me to really
justify what this man is saying because
he is
oda has and i was mentioning this uh in
the rookie summit where
oda has this notion where he likes the
fans to be running around like ants i
think he enjoys us
just wondering what he's going to do
next i think he gets a thrill out of it
because then it gives him more time to
really like i feel like he pays
attention to the community
so much more than we think he does so
when he says things like this
he knows we're all scared like oh my god
one piece is gonna end it's like yeah i
got him like
watch this watch what i'm gonna do so
when he finishes luffy's story allegedly
boom he drops a big hint where it's like
oh my god we got another three years of
one piece get ready guys it's gonna be
great
you know and i feel like he's i think
he's just setting us up
for the grand story of one piece and
it's possible we might get a big big
flashback
that leaves the um perspective of the
straw hats and then we go to the void
century
where we follow joy boy for a little bit
and that's why i'm going into wild head
cannons but
it's a possibility that he could do
something like that bro i feel like this
opens up so many doors
let me yeah i mean the lighting is okay
like you're so bright and i'm like
sitting here in this
red room it's like i'm in a toaster um
[Music]
yeah i feel like this opens up so many
doors because like before that it was
kind of like oh yeah like
oda is trying to get this done at some
point like i want to like
trying to get the story to be over
trying to finish up trying to finish up
and it's like oh well five years maybe
another five
but i feel like now that he's actually
said oh five years to like the climax of
raftel
and then open end whatever i feel like
there's a lot of [ __ ] that can go down
after that right like it sounds pretty
intense so i so are you familiar with
maggie at all
uh the the rough concept but like
haven't read it
haven't uh so explain please
so i'll um i'll i'll do this as least
spoilery as i can but there is a moment
in the manga
where you get to a point where it seems
like it's definitely the end point mr
morris is trolling each other yeah
someone someone banned
um there is a point in magi where you
get to a point where you think it's the
end
and they go into a massive flashback
arc that basically tells the entire
story of the world
and that arc is like one of the one of
the best arcs i've ever seen period
and it explains everything that happened
in the past
as an arc and then we go back to the
present day
and in the present days it's like
expanded into a completely different
direction with like
it's almost like we got new characters
as a result of that arc and i think what
oda is about to do
is once you get to that say we get to
raftel
find one piece and then everything blows
up i think we're gonna get
something very similar where we figure
out what happened in the void century
and we get a whole arc
to explain everything and then the whole
world is opened up as a result
that'd be cool okay so is this how it
went down in maggie
yes and it's called the alma turon arc
so for the magi stands that are in there
they'll know exactly what i'm talking
about but i just don't want to
i don't want to spoil for anyone who's
still interested uh in reading it but if
that does happen oda could
do some crazy things dude in general
like i feel
i feel like there's so much like for
first of all like i think
i hope you're all as happy as i am and
as i think jay is
and i think more just in the comments or
maybe more just not as happy i don't
know
i think more just probably kind of like
ah more one piece
but yeah but yeah like i think we're all
happy that it's gonna
be that long and as you said i feel like
there's so many possibilities
um that you know i personally have so
many ideas what could go down
i personally what i would really like to
see in one piece is like i hope that
rough tell and like finding the one
piece will be such a mind [ __ ] moment
as oda says that basically afterwards
it'll be a completely different story
it's like like there would be an attack
on titan right i'm not sure if you're
following right like
there's an outsider yeah like there's
the outside world and everything like
that
it's like changing our perspective of
the story so fundamentally
that like once we hit that level and
luffy actually becomes pirate king it's
like oh
this is like a completely different
story than what we've been reading like
the first
right thousand two hundred chapters
whatever and then like that's what oda
means it's like okay like till then
it'll be the
pirate adventure becoming pirate king
and afterwards it'll be something
completely different
see and that's what i'm hoping for
because one thing that i've seen with
the one piece community in itself right
so if you notice the amount of
excitement that happened around the
reverie right um
we drifted away from the straw hats
perspective right everyone was so
interested to learn about the world
shanks vivi cobra shichibukai goro say
everyone was like yo it's finally time
and then oda just goes away to wano and
everyone's like oh my god i hate it
right
what if oda had it all planned out to
the point where
he let he gave us a hint of what's about
to happen in one piece
after wano and after after
rage what if we're just about to get a
massive
reverie-like arc now that
oh man i don't know man i wanna i wanna
see the politics i'm not gonna lie i
feel like that's pretty dope
i need more politics yeah for sure um
thanks for the super chat super shiba
he's asking me to greet my german
audience so
as always uh greetings to my german
audience
um yeah no bro like 100 um
i i've been digging like you can say a
lot about
post times good versus pre-time skip but
one of the things i've
heavily enjoyed post time skip is like
all the politics and like the more
like the larger world building we're
getting and like that's something i've
crazily enjoyed about wanna already and
like i i want
more of that for sure do you feel like
it's
something where you see one piece moving
into an even more
like say in a niche kind of niche
after rough tell or is it more like ah
no like this has always been a shonen so
kind of like it's different but we'll
keep going with the same
well i would i would say with one piece
it's very interesting because we
actually had a conversation about this
how people wish one piece was more dark
one piece has a lot of
dark themes look at big mom look at
um the tamriel beto slavery all of that
one piece has a very
um the world of one piece has a very
dark history so if oda is planning to
take the story in a direction where we
go into politics
we know who rules the politics of the
world and it's the world government
and if something so heinous happened
that we had to block out an 800
year period of history can you imagine
what went on in that history
exactly can you imagine because that
would lead into a direction where one
um one piece could get much darker than
what it is and then
um one thing i am worried about just a
little bit and and
i'm assuming you've read you said you
read attack on titan so oh please and
they haven't told me too much because
i'm only caught up with
with uh where the anime is so um okay
but you saw the politics are yes yes yes
yes yes
so a lot of people were annoyed about
that
because it wasn't the same action
saying like everything was like hell
it's not the same thing it's all
politics at that point
i feel like one piece is set up in a way
where if it gets to a political art
it's gonna be very well received and
then we're gonna learn
more about one why are the tamriel veto
so brutal why are they so
hell bent on their own superiority and
to me i feel like there had to be
an inferiority complex that the
attendant the
the descendants of the tamriel beto had
to have and then there was like a
violent lash out against whoever was
above them at the time
in order for them to get to that
pedestal do you know what i'm saying
there is something sinister in the past
with the temporary beto that leads to
their behavior
where they consistently have to oppress
those that are beneath them okay
you know i see so i can definitely see
them going in a sane and ish route but i
don't know if oda will actually show it
i think he'd rather say it implies you
mean yeah i wonder
i wonder because i think he wants like
in general i felt like there's moments
where oda wants to go that way
like with that scene and wanna where
like there's that like about to kill the
baby out of hunger
and it's like you're you're not showing
it but like he's implying it and you you
do have the feeling like at times he
wants to take that step but his editors
are probably like ah you know you like
keep it keep it light
but what you're saying what i think is
interesting is i do
one like since that time limitation is
now kind of gone
um for after off tell i wonder do you
think we get like an entire
void century flashback arc where it's
like
a hundred chapters just one piece
history or something like that like
because i think that would be pretty
dope
i am leaning towards an arc and if it's
an arc i feel like oda could really
bring it's like
because you know there's a lot of a
couple of detractors like oh pre-time
skip it was better
i feel like if we get that void century
arc i think that all goes away i think
it just goes away completely because
knowing how oda writes his story if he
just has free reign
it's kind of like he has a blank slate
right right and it's just like i get to
read i got to write a story from scratch
all over again
with the voice entry because we know
nothing about it
so think about what he can do and then
think about the small so like um
i'm trying to think of an example right
so think about um
uh monkey d dragon right and what he
might know about the fourth century or
what
the um the philosophers
scientists philosophers of o'hara think
about what they learned from the
ponoglyphs and then we
learned what it is they truly learned
that caused the buster call
and then we have a we pay homage back to
what happened on her you know
your name of course it's like
he can basically make any arc that
happened in pre-time skip
ah that'd be so dope it could make it
deeper than it's ever been before so
it's just like oda has a
blank slate if he does that flashback he
has a blank slate to blow our minds
no matter what he does you're completely
right and like one of the things i've
been thinking about i feel like that
connects really nicely to what you just
said
is that one thing i've always been super
confused about is why
introduce emu and like why introduce him
that late into the story
because it felt like if you're trying to
rush towards the end right like why
introduce like another
major villain like this like the over
like the overarching
villain kind of right like why introduce
that so late on if you're like rushing
or trying to rush the end
now i feel it makes a lot more sense
because like now you actually do have
time to like dive
deep into like how did that guy end up
at the top of the world
right like what hap like how did he
even take power in the first place like
has he always been there is it like
someone that's immortal is that is that
something that's like
more like of a heritage thing so now it
makes a lot more sense to actually
include these elements into the story
that late on because
now you actually do have the time frame
to explore these things as well and then
i personally think like correct me if
i'm wrong but i would personally see
blackbeard as the major villain for this
first story part
becoming pirate gift and i think we're
going to get a lot like into him after
wano
but then after that probably it's going
to switch to the world government in eem
sama and then like i feel like now
with that like the world government
might actually have like a lot more in
store in terms of power and like
hard-hitting
like weap like hidden weapons whatever
it is right like
i don't know i'm really like it gets me
really excited just like thinking about
it
there's just so many different
possibilities and another thing this
came into my head where
if you look at the anno cover story and
you know the theories about the moon and
the moon
gonna be a thing are there that many
moons and then we were talking about how
we'd learn more about o'hara
and then you look at the whole um
the little world map or what what the
what are they called normally um
what do you mean the planetarium there
is oh yeah yeah
they have the planetarium and we have
like eight moons and if
we do have that void century flashback
and say we go
into depths about emu's backstory or why
the temporary beats wear those
spacesuits
right you know and i mean we know
there's like space pirates
there's the moon right like like i used
to say
going to the moon in the story wouldn't
make sense
in that time like once again in that
time frame now i'm like
if we have another 10 years like go to
the moon whatever like
i'm happy to explore that yeah i mean i
talked about that before in like uh
one of the very rare theory videos that
i upload
and uh i do talk about the moon theory
right um that's that
that like actually different races used
to live on different moons
i'm like with the pen i'm like the guy
you know that meme we're like the reds
but yeah so i do feel like there's a lot
there to explore and i feel like oda
introduced it for a reason
so i wonder if like the different races
actually came down you know from
different moons or planets
to the blue planet and then like that's
where all the
like racial conflict started and like
the race is trying to like
live together and then probably being at
war
and then someone called joy boy coming
along and like unifying them
and then like someone else coming along
and like breaking up that kingdom
so yeah i don't know man i'm like super
hyped for that
oh also i see we have 1 000 almost 1 500
people in the chat so uh greetings
i don't know hi what i don't know what
you said
tell him what's up man how you doing
what's up chad hi
chad
[Laughter]
you gave everyone one sole entity as
this chat and that's
it chat's cool
so then my question is right so if we
take on what
rayleigh said to luffy um and sabori as
you can come to your own conclusion
about the history of the world right so
they know the history of the world
already
and they didn't do anything about it and
i just think roger just had no interest
in that i think roger was solely there
for the adventure right and we obviously
aligned luffy with the same
um mentality as roger yeah i think the
one caveat that will make luffy
more interested in the history of the
world is his father
dragon okay because dragon is
yep you think there's more to explore
there like do you because like until now
i kind of felt like
you know like dragons and luffy's
relationships kind of gonna be like
they're gonna meet and but it's like
like luffy was back then when garp
talked about it it's like oh i don't
really care who my father is and so on
and so forth but i think you're right
like
now the revolutionaries themselves might
play a much more important role
actually um than they used to i would
agree sorry keep going
no 100 and and i think that all ties in
because
we haven't got we've rather got anything
about one the true
the reason why dragon is doing what he's
doing like we have the surface level
reason right right but i feel like there
has to be something deeper that he knows
about the world government
and in order for luffy to have the
motivations to actually take on the
world government because i don't really
think he cares
is that something has to happen with
dragon there has to be a meeting between
luffy and dragon where dragon's ideals
either influences luffy or something
happens to dragon after he has a
conversation with luffy that motivates
luffy
to actually take on the world government
because what we've seen with luffy is
there has to be something that he's true
sorry do you feel you feel that luffy
right as he's right now he
would not necessarily take that next
step against the world government
without someone pushing him a little bit
yeah i don't think he cares that much
honestly i think luffy's only goal
is his adventure and his freedom now if
his freedom is
threatened or his ideology that he lives
by
is threatened that's normally what
causes luffy to be motivated
like whether someone's freedom is
threatened in a way
from someone that's close to him that's
when he'll act
so i feel like dragon has to have some
sort of
connection with luffy and then it has to
be compromised
how you're reading the chat because i
got you i just saw it i just thought
johnny legend impregnated me i beg you
oh by the way i think we got a super
chat uh let me check
all we need is for best guy ever to show
up and we'll have the three hottest
one-piece boys on the youtube
on stream i don't know who the who who's
best guy ever i'm not sure
but appreciate it i can definitely vouch
for jd
like i also want him to impregnate me
for sure
[Laughter]
stop flattering me man listen bro i'm
about to risk it all but
who's best guy ever i wonder i don't
know but i want to i want to find who
this guy is
if you had to speculate who you think it
would be
um are you saying it's a code name like
a joy boy maybe
like i would say it's like a one piece
youtuber probably huh i would say morris
you know more so pretty handsome
marshall's pretty cute
damn i think i i i throw more in the
ring i would throw moyes in the ring
okay
i'm curious i'm gonna go with uh
what's this out there oh no i don't i
don't want to like uh make people feel
bad
i think brago is hot yeah you know
brocco is a rock
he's got that nice mature look right he
got like settled down with him you know
what i'm saying
this guy is more like he's a good head
of the household you're right
you're right okay there we go i think
moore's busy
something oh there's oh now i see people
catching on here in the chat
oh it's a youtube it's actually a
youtube channel okay
the chat is chat on youtube oh my god
yeah oh my goodness but yeah go ahead
sorry
i interrupted trust me the moment you
started laughing i knew what you were
laughing at i was like oh my god
now but um i think long story short is
like i feel like
this is a chance for luffy and dragon to
kind of have like an interaction
right and then once we have that
interaction luffy actually cares about
dragon's mission
as a result and then from from that
luffy is all of a sudden looking at the
world government differently and then
say dragon dies
oh right do you know what i mean i do
know then
then we'd have the conflict with garp
we'd have a conflict with luffy
we'd have a conflict with the world
government and then we learned about the
world government and what dragon was
truly trying to fight for and that's
when we take the time skip
right now flashback into the void
century do you know what i mean
yeah 100 no i would agree greetings to
silver
we are weird i think we can attest to
that oh yeah but i'm proud of that
that's fine oh for sure
yeah um no i think i think that's really
like
in general ah this like blows my mind i
feel like um
i'm happy we can talk about this i know
that there will be like a ton
of videos about all this because like oh
yeah this changes a lot
i just hope oh no [ __ ] i think my camera
just died
i'm gonna switch to my webcam one sec
but uh yeah i think i'll see you on
hangouts yeah you're good oh yeah yeah
it's just like because i used my
my canon to start okay i was like going
fancy
so yeah but like uh fair enough i did
not
charge it completely since yesterday so
it's gonna be low quality right now
let's see uh but yeah i think like this
opens up so many
so many new
opportunities let me let me quickly you
have to entertain the stream for one
second while i figure out the settings
here
oh sure all right well let's let's start
with the slides agenda let's start with
the strategy agenda all right so
my theory is that the blonde haired
gorosei is actually the grandfather
there you go of sanji you know what i'm
saying he might actually be a vinsmoke
because we do know the gorosei are
really old you know
and there was also the theory about the
fact that
if the gorosei are actually a lot older
than
we think they are because they know
about the voice entry it's either that
there was an old gorilla say and they
passed a little knowledge to them
or there is some sort of
i want to say immortality but there's
some sort of correlation between the age
of
emu right and the eight of the gorillas
so then what if sanji actually ends up
being the key
to finding imu by seeing his grandfather
in the
and he has the conversation you know
what i'm saying and then sanji's all of
a sudden
this really important character and he
just becomes better than zorro and
everything
that he does i think that would be a
great part for the story i think that
would be wonderful
in my personal opinion of course i'm
super curious about that as well
like i still wonder i'm still waiting
for laws through to like
because like it's so it's so prominent
and people were chasing after it so it
does sound like someone got that eternal
youth surgery done
and like i wonder is that imu is that
like someone else
um uh because there has to be a
precedent for it right so
if we're like being actually serious
like ignoring all the sanji stuff right
the girls they
are very old you see they're very old
and that knowledge was passed down
or it's a case it's just a case of a
matter that somehow their affiliation
with emails allow them
to live as long as imu has so then
one is the opi me part of that
because eternal life has to come around
somewhere it's going to come up because
law is still in the story
the last thing that's remaining for law
is that
eternal life factor of the opioid
opinome so it's either going to come up
in wano
or it's going to come up with the world
government
maybe i'm just i'm like i feel like in
general i'm wondering like
for example i think i'm not sure who
threw that around that like the the
world government is like monopolizing
certain devil fruits to just reuse them
yes so that would be interesting um
there's so many interesting concepts
i think we got another super chat
somewhere from
vulgar man very nice username thank you
ahara x tagging collab when
you ask the man
[Laughter]
no i don't know uh i wonder what
what kind type of call-up would i do
with teching i wonder but like not that
i'm not open to it
but i don't i don't have that video in
mind
now but the chat is actually mentioning
um dr kureha which is interesting
because
corey has still alive and kicking and
she keeps mentioning do you want to know
my secret to eternal life
now if that is the case depending on how
long dr kuroha lives
that might be another um hint to what's
going on with the gorosei as well
i do wonder if she's going to be
relevant again because i actually do
have a video
coming out tomorrow as it happens oh
funny that you'd mention it um talking
about the entire
hero look uh yeah scene flashback thing
so um and there like a big focus is
gonna be
inherited will and the will of d right
which like comes up
um a lot and like for the first time
actually ever in that
in that scene on drum island and like
correa is actually the first person to
name drop gold roger as goldie roger and
it's talking about the will of thee so
i'm like now that you mention her and
that the chat is mentioning her more i
wonder if there is like more
to her character that she might know
really interesting i feel like there has
to be just because i remember i
re-watched drum island like a month ago
and when corey hall mentioned gold d
roger and the will of d
i said korea knows a lot more than i
think we all do
and she's going to come back in the
story at some point she has to right
she's like what is she going to say and
she was at the reverie
or was she there with dalton she was
there with dalton oh wow
remember she was talking about the the
secret to eternal life in the referee as
well she was trying to tell her to be
correct
you sir are correct i did not think
about that you're right
yeah in general like the drama like
going back to it and like analyzing the
the flashback it was like drum island
was super fascinating because in like
a lot of ways it's so detached from the
entire baroque work saga but at the same
time it does contain
so much like major themes of the story
which is like really
really cool it's like a really
underestimated arc i feel
in general it is and it's the first
mention of blackbeard
actually in the entire story was in drum
island because he was at drum island
before um
luffy and them had arrived right that's
true yeah and then
and then in the anime i think i don't
know if it's canon in the manga but ace
also
had his first appearance in drum island
at the end of it as well in the end
you're right you're right and they
talked about blackbeard also yeah
yep yep you're correct right there was
like a lot of setup there up there
crazy drum island was drum island was
good man really good arc
and i liked like i liked the ambient
like really unconnected but the ambient
of the arc was really nice like the snow
and like i love that stuff like i'm a
snow person so i also love it
you get a high five to the camera um
[Music]
i'm late i'm sorry i'm late
[Laughter]
that was cool nobody tell us something
different um we got another super chat
from john d
mann again i i love usernames on youtube
that's like
there so far i love that um asking how
do you see the inner turmoil of the
marines playing
a part in the end game that is a
fantastic question actually i would love
to get into that
do you want to start with your take or
sure um i think what's interesting is
you have
fuji torah who is clearly opposed to the
way the old system was but that system
was in place for a specific reason right
and the only way that system the only
reason that system was you know
overhauled was because of what happened
with ssg but then we also have smoker
we have smoker we also have kobe so we
have three individuals within the
marines
and garp as well because you know garp
hates the tamriel beto in general all
right so there's a lot of
individual characters where their
justice does not align
with the world government at all so
there is a possibility when we get to
the story outside of say luffy finding
the one piece or someone finds the one
piece right and we get into
the next story that's not luffy centric
there could be a mutiny within the
marines
where there is a clear division and that
could be part of say the final war
that oda is because i don't know if it
was in
yeah i don't know if oda mentioned it in
the sbs or just a separate um
interview but the final war is going to
blow our minds yeah so a mutiny within
the marines and a war within the marines
and the pirate world itself
would add much more excitement
and i don't think it's anything that we
would actually predict
so if that does happen 100
it's just like the world is in complete
chaos and was like where is it going to
stop there's no end in sight and that's
what a true final war would be like
where
there is no end in sight and there has
to be one big thing
that puts everything on hold you want
you want to know what i think
i would even go a step further uh big
rhetorical question in there
um what i would actually or what i can
actually see if it's really something
that's supposed to blow our minds
i personally could even see someone like
anakainu
and like the marines as an like the
entire organization actually
change places because we see that akainu
is not very happy with like the gorosei
already right like he was there um
what was it like i think it was about
what was about they were fighting about
something was it like after dressrosa
i think it was after dressrosa and the
fact that um doflamingo
was allowed to continue as a shichibukai
after they learned what happened and
they covered up
what happened on undress rosa and
al-qaeda was furious like he was like
what are you guys doing you're right and
then
oh yeah and uh so what i personally
oh you're still there i think he froze
there for a second oh there we go
um yeah so what i could see is really
like the world government and emu and
like the goro say harboring
such amounts power right that
and like that you know that you can only
oppose by actually the entire
like cast of one piece working together
in the end
like that would be something interesting
but i mean the marines in general like
that there will be a split one way or
the other i feel has already
been set up um through like i mean even
this chapter with drake right like this
entire sword thing
and like drake siding with luffy and
then you had kobe obviously you have
smoker you have how kiji
i'm not even sure i'm sure i forget like
some other marines that might be
sympathetic
to the to the straw head course so like
there's already this group
set up right inside the marines um
that's already sympathetic to luffy's
cause and then we also know that
even people like akainu who are still
like
still considered one of the major
villains even he has like his issues
with the world government so external
and then i'm quickly going to hide you
one sec i think right back
i think the something that would be
interesting right
is that if there is mutiny within the
marines
and say that that um those pawns because
i think the guru said to see the marines
as pawns
if they are no longer able to rely on
the marines right there is a possibility
of
us seeing the true hidden power okay of
the world government because a lot of
people believe the girls they might be
combatants of some sort right and i'm
not going to say like
the girls are going to solo the world no
what if there's something that they've
always had say example that straw hat
that's underneath uh mary joyce
that's another thing if oh my god you're
right
you see what i'm saying like what if
there is something that they have
that is capable of of its being of it
being its own military source
and then that's revealed after the
mutiny of the marines
and then we have another opposition that
we have to deal with
you're right you know and then and then
emu
is possibly the only one who has control
over it the only one who can command you
what i mean so is this like
there are so many things and i feel like
then the like there's some yeah like you
said there's so many things in the story
that
would make so much more sense like the
ancient weapons actually like if you had
that like
real build up to the final war like then
actually
getting a hold of the ancient weapons
and like using them and using shira
hoshi like that makes so much more sense
than if we get like a
proper setup for it um quick i'm just
quickly going to go in like for people
who are late
and like are questioning whether like
i'm just click baiting the [ __ ] out of
this title here
that actually is news and like because
uh
parts of the new sbss have been leaked
and uh one person asked oda if he was
serious about the
uh one piece ending in five years and
his answer was well
actually no it's gonna be five years
until luffy becomes pirate king
which he considers a basically a
closed-off story in itself but
afterwards there will be a
crazy war and like that will blow
everyone's mind and we're basically all
not ready for it
and then there's like basically still no
time limit for that so that's
that's why the clickbaity title i'm sure
the title is below so yeah
yeah um i'm quickly gonna read two more
super chats we got where is it no
i lost it here i joined the stream late
what happened
you're welcome i was early to that
question but thank you for the
thank you for the donation anyway and
toby boris is saying aokiji probably
being a member of sword what are your
thoughts on that personally i think it's
obvious
i would say so too actually like i think
it's at least the most likely
explanation i think like him joining
blackbeard does make very little sense
with the okiji we've met so far so would
say sword is the most likely
um yeah option there he might also just
be a spy for the marines regardless of
sword
what do you think i feel like alkiji
definitely
his form of justice is his own i feel
like he is very
confident in his own form of justice if
you see his interaction with saul
he knew what was going on was wrong and
he was like
i should not let niko robin go i
shouldn't but for the sake of my friend
saul i'm gonna let her go so we know
where his morality lies his immorality
does not align with blackbeard at all it
just doesn't make sense
so right akichi being a part of sword is
almost a foregone conclusion
i just i don't see how it's not it's
either that or he's actually just a
renegade and that's it he's just
finding his own way to make sure his own
justice
is exacted in the world you know
someone's asking what a sword um if in
case you don't know sword is
a secret organization within the marines
that basically
we don't know so much about it yet but
we know that kobe is a part of it
drake's part of it i think those are the
two
confirmed members that are basically
infiltrating or like doing undercover
operations
only for the marines i think uh
or is that official i'm not sure but
it's it's assumed at least
that they're working independently from
the world government's rule and like
from the cps
and so on and so forth right yes that's
the assumption exactly
so that's the state and i think we're
assuming saying goku is the
ringleader of it all right exactly
exactly
um and then yeah
i'm just wondering there's like so many
other things that are still
unknown because yep because you have um
for example a lot of the chatter
mentioning
vegapunk you know vegapunk is
another key to the entire story oh bro
like what
you know so then what does phagophong
know what does he know about the um the
origin of devil fruits
because then the origin of devil fruits
could also be explained
exactly in the void century as well and
dude there's still so many things
it as well that were teased like what
was
oh [ __ ] i just had something in my mind
and i was like that's that's a good
point and now i lost it
keep going with vega punk i'll think
about it so then we have
vegapunk we also have ssg and then one
all right i think people exactly were
asses
that big that big project that's
basically we still don't know what is
sorry
thanks keep going yeah no so ssg is like
one
we were talking about the split between
the marines and
we know from what we've seen the
rhetoric about vegapunk is positive he
doesn't seem like a
um you know an evil person per se he
seems like just a man of knowledge so i
wonder what his reasoning for being
aligned with the marines
is and is he working with
the revolutionaries because you know he
worked on kuma specifically exactly so
then
what is going on with vegapunk in that
sense and i feel like veggo punk is
going to be a much bigger character
than we actually know and understand and
if the marines do have a mutiny
does vega punk go with the marines does
he stay with the world government does
he go to the revolutionary so
interesting
do you think vegapunk might be someone
from the void century as well just based
on the knowledge he has
that is a possibility depending on what
he knows
about right this is a reach but
depending on what he knows about the
opioid know me
because if he knows a lot about devil
fruits and we know about
the recreation of devil fruits is there
a possibility that there is a recreation
of the opioid know me that we don't know
about
okay what i think is interesting is that
i'm not sure who says it when vegapunk i
think it's kumar right
um when vegapunk is first introduced
something like someone says
his technology is basically 500 years in
advance right
to where we're right now and we also
know that the ancient kingdom like
probably was a quite technically
advanced civilization as well so i feel
like
that would make sense in a way that like
someone like instead of vegapunk being
that incredible genius that he either
has a lot of access
to these technologies or is actually
from the void century himself
and has just like carried it on so
that'd be interesting
and like another thing that um i think
also yeah with vagapunk like
because it was a last chapter i think
right that we got
the yeah it was last chapter we got the
reveal that kaido actually bought
those failed ancient giants from from uh
punk hazard yeah and i think we can both
agree that it's probably not caesar who
we bought them from because we can see
that caesar was based basically doing
everything that vegapunk did but a lot
worse
and so like these giants like they might
not be perfect ores but they were pretty
good
way better than what caesar was
producing so i wonder did vegapunk
sell these giants to kaido or like
because like he there are so many
factions that he might be
affiliated with i feel yes
the only thing i would question in that
regard is then that would compromise
where vegapunk stands and his
perspective that we have
of him in the story because we don't see
him as a bad person
and we know for a fact that caesar was
working with kaido and also big mom
so the correlation it's a possibility
that maybe vagapunk left them behind
and then caesar sold them to kaido it's
a possibility that that happened
um we also know that i don't know was
judge wasn't on punk hazard correct
no i don't think so but he has worked
with vegapunk yeah exactly they work
because caesar i think caesar judge and
vegapunk they all work together at one
point didn't they
or am i just reaching here
i would i would just i'm sorry yeah
sorry you're back yeah okay i'm about to
say yeah cause you just stopped i was
like
what happened i thought it was me i'm
not sure what happened
but now i think we're good yeah maybe
the chat killer
we're talking about um
i'll let him know i said we back we're
back
yeah i think i i choked out there for a
second oh yeah looking good
refresh i think we're good okay we're
back yeah
we're back okay we're good it's safe but
yeah
nothing happened
something happened um no what i was
saying was that i think it's really
weird that vegapunk would even you know
hang out with a guy like caesar in the
first place
like he seems smart enough not to do
that
he does but then again you know these
archetypes with these um
people who are only seeking knowledge
that they kind of keep them their
morality doesn't really
mean that much to them the only thing is
that we know that
vegapunk wasn't a fan of the what the
life equation that judge is using for
his soldiers
okay wasn't wasn't vega punk opposed to
that um in the flashback
i do think so yeah i think that's i
think he was opposed to that so then we
know vega punk has some sense of
morality so what you're saying is
it does make sense it does actually make
sense so then
jd you're not a moderator oh no i'm just
vibing
i mean i'm not putting you here and also
where's
cup i would make him a moderator as well
but i don't see him in the chat
so there um we got another super chat
from
alex gregro which is a cool youtube name
um toki was clearly running from
something by hoping by hopping through
time do you believe she was still alive
when the ancient giants were roaming oh
you mean like
ancient giants like in being like just
alive and like mating and like running
around
probably i would say that would make
sense i think oh there we got cup
okay enough moderators for today um
yeah so i think i personally think that
that's very likely
um maybe they're reaching even further
back in time
and maybe i could also see for example
the like i mean this is
like real like out there as a
speculation but maybe they're like they
were created as a
like type of weapon originally during
the void century i could see something
like that
that they like a method for warfare um
once again like since we're already like
50 minutes in
for those people joining right now there
is actually news like we're already
talking about it for quite some time now
but yes
it looks like one piece will not end in
five years but just
will find the one piece in five years
luffy will become pirate king that's
a close story in itself i would assess
in the new sbs and then
afterwards there's gonna be the big war
probably against emu and the
world government and it's gonna blow our
mind so that's the status quo in case
you're wondering
sorry what do you think about the
ancient ancient giant thing
so i think that's a good point because
if you look at the amount of stock that
big mom puts in the giant race and her
alliance with the giants
and how she said she would be able to
dominate the world
um jordan kelly saying ancient giants
are people too
hey man ancient giant lives matter but
um
i can see that being a case where
vegapunk was
the government want more giants
in their ranks and you see with mother
caramel she
basically had a giant farm for the
marines as well so if
mega punk is a if ssg is actually the
perfected version
right of of the giants the ancient
giants that he's trying to create
then that would make sense because then
why would we need
the shichibukai if we have a bunch of
ancient giants right
right you know what i'm saying so like
if that's the hint if that's what oda is
trying to do because if
we've always tried to figure out what
does ssg stand for yeah yeah
so then g could stand for giants
it definitely would make sense yeah it
would make sense and then if oda dropped
that hint about
punk hazard ancient giants there's a
connection between vegapunk and caesar
if you kind of follow the trail between
the hints about the giants and how
important they are
to say the power that they have in this
world and then we also know the story
about oars
or junior maurya is like oh i got ores
now so i can take over the world it
seems like the giants have
a very major role in the balance of
power in the world
and they're saying super soldier giants
now so like
if that's the case if you have giants
that you can actually control
that's that's crazy it is like i feel
like that would be really cool but i
feel like there must be more to it
because like just in the
recent chapters we saw like frankie one
shotting one of like i mean they're not
they're still failed quote unquote but
still you know like it it was basically
set up that the straw hats are
those are basically no hindrance for any
of the straw hats at this point
so i wonder if like that would be a big
enough threat to replay like
to replace someone like mihawk or
replace someone like some of the other
shibukai so
i feel like like i like the giant idea
but i feel like them like either
these giants that they made are like
significant like they have like crazy
devil fruits or [ __ ]
um or or something something other that
gives them like
a sign like they must be i personally
feel they must be stronger than orrs
even in mass
to be like a real threat right
so my argument would only be is if you
have an overwhelming force of giants
that can destroy fighter like just
basically you have to be a top tier
fighter
to be able to beat these giants but if
you have a large amount of giants
one is going to slow you down two the
marines already have soldiers at the
same tier
as these pirates and you know right if
you have a case where the pirate crews
are now
null and void and you only have only a
few certain
certain pirates that they would have to
fight if you have someone like
the marines like um the admirals for
example right you have the admirals you
have akainu you have cp0
you all of a sudden now have a gap where
it's only a
few amount of pirates that are able to
actually deal with the marines and then
they probably believe that their force
of the admirals the vice admirals
and cp0 and maybe some other some other
thing that we don't know about
where they're able to actually overwhelm
the opposition yeah yeah exactly and the
only the only way to counter that
would be the ancient weapons right
because the weapons are known as tools
of mass destruction
so you counter right mass numbers of
destruction with more mass destruction
right right yeah i don't know like like
you like you said i feel like at some
point um
after raftel once we get into this open
area that we're talking about in the
stream
um i do believe there will be like
ancient power versus ancient power
now we should be good
are we good let's see the chat
fff not good
oh oh oh oh
this is not good
stream dead not good oh you're back
that's a good sign yes i'm here
you can hear me that's good
oh [ __ ] oh what happened to the internet
that's not good i wonder if i
oh the chat's coming back so that's a
good sign
okay yeah you're clear now you're like
you're not even lagging on the hangouts
yeah okay that's good that that was
weird
i feel like maybe one of one of my uh
roommates is
annoyed by me and like cutting the
internet or something
trying to send me messages um yeah so
i'm not sure if that came through but
someone please
uh cup if that's possible just post
it looks like we're good oh it looks
like we're good yeah so yeah
um if cup can put the news in the in the
chat every 10 minutes so people know
what's up
that'd be cool and yes let me go back oh
by the way like since
like i'm not sure if i already said that
but in case you don't know that's jd
and like check out his channel it's in
the description below so show him some
love as well he does like some wonderful
content
and i think we missed like some like two
super chats or something so
nicholas alexander asked luffy versus
kizuru next arc after wano i have a
feeling it will be a marine arc with
kizuru being the antagonist
more character focus on him luffy's
legend will skyrocket for defeating an
admiral
i can see that i feel like i mean we did
have the cyber odi arc for kizuru but i
do
think he's like a very wild card
character i like his character a lot
um i would like it if he came back i
think we saw him already
eager to come to juana so it actually
not like if the marines come to wono i
do see kizuru there
as an admiral honestly because he was so
eager to come
i'm hoping he does show up i think we
need a lot more from kizuru because it's
funny
the it seems like the community some of
the some people in the community
downplay cesaro because he's lazy
so they don't think he is nearly as
strong as his other combatants
yeah they don't think he's nearly as
important
i thought everyone agreed that keizer
was probably the most badass of the
three
that's what i mean listen i'm a kizzaro
i love kizzaro for me kizaru is just
like if he
i i pray for the day when i see kizaru
get serious because when i see that bro
i'm telling you because i was going to
do some things
was like he just can't be beat i feel
like cesaro has that potential
right i think i would agree 100
um we got another super chat what about
those ancient weapons voice of all
things the d's luffy's mother
shanks and the gorosei rogers power
shanks power eem sama
cheeky arrival so yeah there's as you're
saying like there's
so much going on i feel that like it's
something that i've been like
like if you listen to the one report um
like me ranting with mortgage
you will know that um we both feel like
there's so much
going on in this like that so many open
like ends that
would be almost impossible to tie up in
five years that like now it makes so
much more
sense and now i'm so much more excited
for these things to actually happen
right also i think we got two new
members
so i'm very happy about that um one is
akagami
abdel that's a pretty cool name that's
my boy oh you know him
oh yeah he's a part of the jd family i
love abdel then
even bigger shout out to you thanks so
much for becoming a member
and also thanks to alex gregro
i think you super chatted earlier so
also welcome on board
much appreciate it i hope you enjoy the
icon um
once again the live chat froze that's
also a very good comment
i will fix that um one simply reiterate
what this stream is about oh there we go
i fixed it yeah
but you can go anyway yeah no so overall
the stream is
about a question and answer between oda
and someone else i'm not quite certain
who it is but they basically asked oda
this question i'll just read the
question
yes for the sake of the chat it says
odachi is it true that one piece will
end in five years
even if that's the case a public
statement like that is really vexing for
the fans
many friends of mine who are fans burst
into tears
with this sudden announcement i feel
like shouting
how could you do this to us but i don't
want to stress you out
and it's from someone called pari
underscore bentham
and oda responds by saying by
ending in quotations i meant the
juiciest part of luffy's adventure
since that's when the mystery of what is
the one piece is to be revealed
right now wano is heating up if luffy is
able to leave here in one piece
we'll get a development that will engulf
the entire world
the likes which no one has read before
the greatest war
in one piece history i said what i said
so that the readers hearts would be
prepared since it will be such a long
arc
and one that will really pin things
towards the finish line
that being said i'm really enjoying
writing and drawing juano right now
and i'm pumped to finish it
i would definitely let you read me a
good night's story
oh thank you i appreciate it i feel i
would sleep very well
hearing that i take pride in that yeah i
know for sure man it looks like it's
meant in the most positive way i can
imagine it was
like wonderful i loved it but yeah so
this is
what this chat is about so i would never
click bait too much so wouldn't go
exactly um but we're already a bit in so
we already talked about it in depth
um there's yeah there's just so so many
so many things i feel like there so
do you have like a topic in mind i'm
quickly going to read the super chat and
then i'm going to ask you
um carlos is saying i know this is off
topic but who do you think is fighting
king
this is a little up just a little of
topic zaro asanji i would love to see
both take him down
sanji you know like king
like i feel like it's been kind of set
up so that would be really dope
i would like i would like to see sanji
i'm fighting king and then like
yeah with the zorro thing like i'm a big
zorro guy like i i do love sanji but i'm
an even bigger zorro guy but like i want
both of them to really shine this like
actually i do want most of the
straw hats to shine these chapters uh
this arc in general so i would like to
see sanji get that fight against king
i think that would be really cool then
we got another
new member somewhere i think there we go
toby boras welcome on board thank you
very much appreciate it i hope you enjoy
the custom
emotes that are available to all members
shameless plug over and what i wanted to
ask you
is i forgot that's not good i had like a
really good question
um oh what was it
is there i wanted to ask you something
about the
sps thing oh yeah yes i remember
sorry is there something you're really
excited to make a video about
now that those news are out so i'm glad
you said that because i have quite a few
video ideas now and they're going to be
personally that you can call them
baseless theories um but
those are the best those are my favorite
ones to make because then my man
one thing that really interested me is
when oda said since that's
when the mystery of what is the one
piece is to be revealed
so i'm curious to wonder
are we gonna learn about what the one
piece is before we
find it because if that's the case
hmm what would that how would that how
would luffy feel about that
i don't think or or if it's a case where
luffy doesn't find out what the one
piece is
but someone else does like blackbeard
and you think we would know when
blackbeard learns
yes i feel like i feel like we would
i wouldn't like that though i think like
i want to find it together with luffy
you know what i mean
so maybe he doesn't tell us per se but
there is a there's like a really really
big hint of the idea of what it could be
so like say blackbeard is like if anyone
gets hands on this
information it would destroy the world
and then we all all of a sudden realize
the context of what the one piece could
be
based on someone else figuring out what
the one piece is right
that doesn't make sense yeah i'm i don't
know man i'm so like
i want i'm so excited for the end game
i'm not gonna lie like i'm i'm so in
love with juano right now but like i
can't wait to see all that like
like one one thing i'm gonna say huh all
good not go ahead no no
i'm saying like i'm adding adjectives
okay i thought we're like choppy again
or something
no no no you're good um what i well like
till now i was always like oh once we
get to raftel the story is almost gonna
be over
and like that kind of gave me like an
almost nostalgic feel where i was like
oh no
like i'm excited but like i'm kind of
like sad gonna be sad once we hit that
point but now like i'm so hyped
before for raftel like i can actually
allow myself to be really hyped
so i'm really looking forward to that
um yeah i don't know i'm just thinking
like are there
do any more things come to your mind
when oh you think about
open ends that might play a bigger role
not now that those
news are out so obviously talking about
the moon
talking about the possibilities of the
void century flashback and i think i
would go
into more depth about the void essential
flashback of what it could be because
i'd be able to talk more about the
example that i used from maggie
to kind of paint the picture of what
could happen because it would involve
a confrontation with the world
government it would involve a
confrontation with luffy and dragon
so you would get videos like the
possible relationship between luffy and
dragon and what would motivate luffy
to combat the new world that's a video
in itself
then you have the possibility of one the
role of the tamribito
what do the tamribito truly represent
and then you get to go into the dynamics
and you can analyze
the way they carry themselves why do the
timbria beto carry themselves the way
they do
and then we could go back to little
hints in the story about the d
clan um go to the long-leg tribe
the three i remember um the importance
of pudding
and the three-i tribe as well right they
have major importance in the world as
well
so there is a race issue here that we
have that there's a bunch of separate
races in this blue planet and then
there's one regular race
so is it possible that the tembrio beto
had subjugation over this race and the d
clan was the opposition
or was it the other way around where the
tamriel vietnam were part of all these
races and then they gain superiority as
a result right
so i think that's a good point also you
said what
oh no i'm just saying like i agree with
you i think that's really interesting
yeah there's like there's there's so
many things that you can go into where
this news alone is probably going to
create content for like the next six
months
for sure there's gonna be a lot like i
see i see jb in the chat
a shout out to like if you want to join
ma'am um i can send you the link but
like if you prefer to just
watch that's also fine i'm sure you have
a lot uh gonna be a lot to do
in uh like in the next month um jb
saying i'm actually starting to buy six
or seven years
addressing it in an sbs as a powerful
move i do 100 degree and i'm i'm not
even sure i would agree with the six to
seven years to be honest
i like kind of i'm like i could serve it
longer yeah
like kind of but like let's i'd also be
happy with like two more years
but like i also could see 10. um thanks
shadow for becoming a member we reached
20 of 20 did not expect this tonight at
all but
much appreciated once again um i'd love
to see it
in case you're excited like interested
like i work together with pitch art
a really good artist who's like creating
custom emotes and also for my members
so in case you're into that too yeah
yeah
oh so don't forget to uh check out this
very kind person that's doing this with
me tonight i love her
it's in the description below for jd's
channel as well
so get this guy uh some love he's
definitely one of my favorite people on
the internet that i'm friends with
i appreciate you man you're one of my
favorites too man thank you thank you
thank you very much much appreciated
um i think i i think i chased uh jb away
but oh there he is blink me i was just
about to say
there it is let's see there was
something oh my god there was something
i wanted someone some
someone said something really
interesting oh yeah he said racer's
gonna be really important i'm sorry
whoever you are starts with areas um
chronosity
he said race is going to be big what is
king
the point of king is really interesting
right because
king is the only one of his race left
right
right so what if king is another key
to what happened in the voice entry
because we know there's been purges
before
there hasn't only been one purge so what
if king was
what if king's lineage was part of a
purge right
and then as a result we learned this is
like all these races that we have like i
mentioned before
race is such a big issue in one piece
that old as harptone especially with the
fishman
now there's a case where there could be
one specific race
that may be allied with the d clan
because you know the d clan was purged
what if king's race was a part of the
people that were actually allied with
the d-clan as well
and they were a result of the same purge
oh that would be cool
i i think that's that's a really
interesting
idea i will have to think about that i
will have to think of it that's a really
good thought
um thanks cup for putting jd's link also
in the chat
i see someone subscribed already so
that's cool um seiko is saying
man bun time 20 members so i i told
people
if we reached 20 members yesterday that
i would show how my hair looks like
without the
knot so it's like this
in case you're wondering um like i'm
actually i'm honestly growing it out for
the very first time i'm usually a very
like military hairstyle type of person
but i thought like
i want to have long hair once in my life
my bus got lead yeah
dude you look yolk smooth man i
appreciate that
i have not gotten the haircut yet but i
need one
really and i'm excited to go yeah so
like the way my hair is
first of all it looks pretty good and
second didn't i see you like posting
something
on twitter the other week i like to do
that a lot when i get a haircut i'm
feeling myself normally so
it's like two weeks every two weeks
that's like the timeline for a black
man's hair yes
every two weeks yes because the hairline
is very important to a black man and the
fade the fade always has to be crisp no
matter what
that sounds so expensive though it is
like well
it's like what 25 it's okay i mean
everything for being beautiful i guess
i appreciate you see like i save all
that barbie mommy at the moment
yeah but listen man you have the long
flowing hair like you could fit in in
l.a immediately and all the girls like
oh my god he's probably a surfer or a
skateboarder you know what i mean you
just get it to meet
and you're german look man all i'm
saying is if i have a girlfriend stay
away from her bro i don't want you near
her that's all i'm saying
appreciate it man though like i'm not
sure about l.a at the moment like it
looks like blade runner there
oh yeah no with the fires no okay yeah
but but still appreciate it man yeah
pray for california
for sure for sure man like yeah like
this is like let's get back to topic but
like
america at the moment is like looking a
bit dim
from the outside at least listen man we
we try to get by 2020 is bad enough
for sure we're just trying to survive
exactly
but in better news in case you're new to
the to the stream uh
2020 at least has one good thing that we
found out that one piece is not gonna
end in five years
that oda actually addressed this in an
sbss and which is what we're talking
about
right at the moment i'm not sure i sent
a jb the link not sure if he got that
but he might just be setting stuff up so
we're waiting
um it definitely felt like um
the one-piece walls were closing in
for sure and like i'm sure it's not only
me but like
i saw a lot of creators already like i
mean like i'm genuinely
also enjoying you know spreading out my
content and like i want to cover more
stories
but at the same time i'm still feeling
like it was something like oh i kind of
feel like oh if this is ending in a
couple of years like you don't want to
be in the spot where it's just ending
and you're like oh
i kind of ran out of content now you
know so i'm very
thankful for that as well next to the
thing you know obviously that i just
want to keep reading that story
i think i think that if there's a time
to pay attention to
one piece content creators now i think
now is like the best time because
there's going to be so many different
things that we haven't thought of
in this stream that other content
creators are going to come up with
and you know what i mean it could be
because you know in the old days in the
one piece community there's always that
one theory that
catches everyone's attention and it kind
of just blows up and then all of a
sudden it creates a whole nother
it changes your perspective on so many
different things in the story right and
then generates bigger conversation as a
result so i think with this news
we're about to have like another little
bubble of like one piece theories that
are coming out of nowhere i'm sorry and
i feel like it might be like a really
important like uh you know another
trigger
for more people to actually make the
move into the one piece community and
like and
like since it's actually you know gonna
keep going for a couple of years
so i do see that at the same time it
also makes me wonder like how much of a
marketing
stunt that was the five years oh man
this is what i keep telling people man i
was like oh i wanna keep lying man i'm
telling you he just keeps
it's all it's a trick always a trick man
i wonder do you do you feel like it's
just something he's enjoying or do you
think it's
more something like his editors are just
saying like no bro we should like
probably pump
those numbers a bit i think
if you see the way he answers our
questions like a troll
oda is just a troll i think he just
loves
trolling his community i think he just
gets a kick out of it i think it's just
funny to him
i wonder if it sometimes feels like he's
way more like
not necessarily the english community
but like maybe the japanese one but it
feels like he's much more aware
of what people are saying and theorizing
than people who give him credit for it
oh i say they say jb's uh popped in
how's it going
what's up jb yo can you hear me we can
hear you
loud and clear yes sir awesome do i
sound good
much appreciate this is the first time
we actually uh talk person to person
yeah i'm kind of a rare pokemon very
happy that i caught you
um yeah much appreciated man like uh
yeah i have no idea
that you that you dropped by i'm really
happy what you guys i
actually like talking about i've been
zoned out for like five minutes what are
you guys actually talking about
uh well we were just talking about how
it was basically how it like now it
feels like in retrospect like this and
like we already suspected that but like
that the five-year thing was just like
this big marketing stunt
by what is editors yeah and then he was
trolling yeah
i mean that's that's what i that is what
i think right so like the big thing is
is one piece got passed
up in uh sales by uh demon slayer
and i think the one piece staff has been
really i guess stressed out and
pressured
in order to improve sales and one of the
hardest things that
they have to to overcome is the fact
that one piece is so long
like you can just start in one oh that's
how desperate they are so you know
i do see that but at the same time
bringing it up into sbs is um
i don't know it changes it for like a
little bit for me i think
right i would agree and like i do feel
like they
try to set up wano as an opportunity
right for people to jump
back into the story at this point it's
kind of like what i feel like they've
been trying to do right like saying like
oh
even if you haven't been you know
keeping up with the story now is a good
chance to like jump back in
well 100 agree i think one yeah i mean
it's just it's just
but we're like i think we're a bit laggy
sorry i think i cut out because i
think i'm lagged a little bit so
actually joe but i did have a question
for you
um because we're talking about a lot of
open-ended theories that we have here
and you're obviously the theory king
so if you can't hear me i'm curious to
see what does
the meant the comment about um luffy's
story once that's ended that we're going
to get a larger development that's going
to engulf the world what does that mean
to you like where does that take your
mind
at
let's see we're still here i mean
the world's government essentially and
and
justice and power i mean mort's made a
video that i just watched that is
probably on point this whole
conversation relating to
the marines and the pirates and what
justice stands for and who has power
and um you know and
the kind of significance that holds in
the world right and
is tackling i guess is inequality right
it's a very whether it be between
uh you know nobles and peasants or
whatever race that you might be um and
so i mean that's where this that's the
end game of the
story i think that that'll tie to one
piece and and
right and the voyage entry and all that
it all come together
but um i mean that's just i guess that's
the end game as i see it that's what the
massive conflict is going to be about
let me just put your channel there in
the description
as well and into the chat i'm 100
with you on that joy boy because i was
mentioning that the world government
itself has always been a major plot
point that we need to address but now
that we know there's going to be a
bigger development
outside of the story or the adventure of
luffy
it just means that the world government
the history of the world government
the relationship between the tamriel
beto and the civilians the relationship
between the gorosei
and the marines it's going to be blown
up into a much
bigger story where there could possibly
just be an
arc solely dedicated to those relations
that you mentioned
and as a result of that it's like what
are the hints that oda has left because
now we're gonna have to go we're gonna
have to start searching through the
story again
and see what are the hints that oda has
left between the relationship of the
world government
marines scorsese and the civilians that
we missed before
and i think that's just going to be like
a a segway into like a brand new levels
of discussion that we're going to have
in the community yeah i mean i mean
there's so many
like i would like to hear your take on
that jb i mean for you it must be a
a dream because we i talked about it
with jdb for like an hour now but
there's so many
loose ends and like so many like hints
in the story that
didn't make so much sense before like
the emo thing why introduce like this
big of a character that late in the
story right like now
if we actually have that time to spend
on these characters and like on certain
flashbacks maybe get like a
small arc about the void century even i
feel like now
a lot of things actually make a lot more
sense that oda has introduced very late
in the story
what's your take on that i i just want
to i want to clarify here i haven't
actually read
the sbs yet so if you say anything
specific at all
it's like i just kind of i kind of
zoomed in there i've only seen the
about five years uh but um so if there's
any like specific wording
yeah the only impression that i got from
the sps so far based on is like it seems
like
elbaf and rafal is that whole
situation might not might not
take as long as as long as it seems
that's
the endgame
a little bit choppy here yeah a little
bit tends to
you know bring this out but i think my
theory is is
essentially like there's this is is it
me
oh yeah i think you're back you're good
you're good yeah he has a bit of a delay
so we're gonna have to wait for him to
respond yeah just a little bit but he's
good
yeah i i keep i keep talking over y'all
and then you all keep talking and i'm
like
exactly we keep talking over each other
but it's fine uh we're getting used to
it
yeah so my bad i'll i'll be somewhat
silent here so i don't screw the the
flow of the stream oh don't worry i mean
uh
yeah i mean my whole thing though is
like is like
there there's a lot that oda intends to
delve into at some point in time
relating to
pirates as a whole and it's like it's
one of the big questions that we have as
well is is what is blackbeard's role in
the story right so final pirate
antagonist
but how does that relate to the in-game
battle like who's the bigger threat is
blackbeard the bigger
you know how do those things come
together who who ultimately plays the
role of
a final villain and that's something
that we still i mean we still don't know
you can have your opinion one way or
another but you know
so i mean some theories that i have on
this is like for instance
you know maybe the world government came
into existence in order to protect the
world from
pirates so again i'm i just watched some
more videos so it's like fresh on my
mind but you know justice where do you
stand um
and how justice changes right so when at
this particular point in time
luffy is the hero even as a pirate he
doesn't follow the rules but that is in
fact the right thing to do because the
world is so rotten
but if the world was less rotten than
not following the
the rules would be the wrong thing to do
you would then be evil right and so it's
it's this like
pendulum sort of deal and so maybe at
some point in time in the past the world
government was good
and they fought against pirates such as
blackbeard or kaido
um and you know we'll delve into that
and so it sort of leads into a story in
which maybe blackbeard is the final
antagonist of like
you know i'm not sure that is that is a
really interesting take
for sure yeah there's so much
little there's so much little
information out there to remember that's
like
in a live setting it's like how can you
consider all of this yeah like you gotta
sit down and
you know like write out several pages of
notes for uh
i think he cut out a bit but yeah i'm
i'm with him on the several notes
thing because he actually just muted so
it's actually funny right so
go harping on what first of all what job
i said about the fact that the
world government actually could have
been good at first and then something
happened
that changed the way they dealt with the
world
is very interesting right because if
there's one thing we know for sure and i
think this is not something we've
mentioned o'hara
fishman island is very important to the
world in general oh 100
fishman island is very important and in
my plans this is actually
another answer to the question you asked
me about content i was going to create
my plan was to re-read fishman island
all over again and do my first
giant analysis video it was in the works
right you want to do that
scripted and everything so i was going
to do that and then with this
it seems as though i can dig deeper into
fishman island now as a result
of what we've just learned because we
know we're going back to fishman island
we know joy boy
visited fishman island we know he
apologized to someone on fishman island
i'm assuming it was the former president
right if something happened in the void
century
that led to the discrimination of
fishman island or
where the fishermen came from to begin
with
because one of the fishermen weren't
actually a thing before and then in the
void century the fishman became a thing
you mean that when they made it they
were created
and then you know they obviously
reproduced oh there was i love these
theories
do you see what i'm saying like there's
there's there's a possibility where the
fishermen
were it was like there was a there was a
weird accident or something right or
there was this entity right because
mermaids seem to be just a mythical
existence i feel i feel like that leads
really nicely into what we talked about
earlier with the ancient giants where it
feels like they've been like
almost designed for warfare as well
exactly
yeah and then there is some sort of
interspecies breeding between say the
ancient weapon poseidon
and a human and as a result the
fishermen were created as a result
and then you have the fishman and then
maybe as maybe joy boy had something to
do with that he had to leave
and then there was this um conflict in
the void century that i
that alienated the fishman and that's
where that racism comes from
and then there is such an importance on
what joy boy did was freshman island and
maybe they were above
at one point i don't have seen the movie
atlantis where atlantis was above ground
at one point and then they had to sink
atlantis down to the bottom of the ocean
maybe fishman island
was sunk down to the bottom of the ocean
and that's
it was to protect them from the world
government
and then you have this whole this was
actually somewhat clarified this is
really yeah what's up my bad my bad it
makes it i think this was somewhat
clarified
yeah this was somewhat clarified in
fishman island where the fishman
just i mean it's straight up said in a
panel
like i could pull the panel up for you
where they used to live up on the
surface whether it was
their island sun oh yeah yeah that is a
planet i personally like the connection
between water seven
but yeah go on go on sorry i'm sorry no
no i was just
affirming here i remember that so
then well that's confirmed then there's
there was definitely an instance where
okay
the fishermen were isolated as a result
of that and then we have joy boy
fishman and things of that nature and
then the key
to what the key to the mystery of this
world in the current day is whatever
went on in fishman island and when we
get that history of what happens fishman
island is going to be
extremely important so i think with this
news
here i think if we look back
at what odin and roger mentioned about
joy boy and that they're waiting for joe
boy and then look at shira hoshi the
relationship
luffy has with shira hoshi if luffy's
supposed to be
joy boy like people are saying and
there's a relationship between luffy
and shira hoshi then maybe we could
create and craft a theory between
that relationship being very very
similar beforehand
that would be interesting no and oh
sorry
you finished you finished first yeah i'm
finished i'm sorry i'm just quickly
going to jump in because i think
i see we have two new members which i
much appreciate uh welcome to
levy flores and let me see tony
petkowicz so thank you very much for
becoming members
and also what i think would be a good
idea at this point once again since it's
been a time
since been a while do you want to read
the the question and the answer gwen
uh jay so then like i think since jb
hasn't
heard the actual phrasing yet it would
be good to like
i think i think you have it pulled up
right yeah i have it pulled up i can
read it again thank you
story time so starting with the ladney
okay yeah
harry underscore bentham asked this
question to oda
odichi is it true that one piece will
end in five years
even if that's the case a public
statement like that is really
vexing for the fans many friends of mine
who are fans burst into tears with a
sudden announcement
i feel i feel like shouting how could
you do this to us
but i don't want to stress you out and
then oda responds by saying
by ending in quotations i mean the
juiciest part of luffy's adventure
since that's when the mystery of what is
the one piece is to be revealed
right now wano is heating up if luffy is
able to leave here in one piece
we'll get a development that will engulf
the entire world
the likes of which no one has read
before
the greatest war in one piece history
i said what i said so that the reader's
hearts would be prepared
since it'll be such a long arc and one
that will really pin things towards the
finish line
that being said i'm really enjoying
writing and drawing wano right now
and i'm pumped to finish it
thoughts jumps
oh man um yeah i mean that's kind of
what i said before you know it's it's
what i've thought about juano from the
the start and of course
it matters what happens to kaido and the
big mom but the events here
are going i mean it seems to me like
it's very possible and this
sbs seems to imply that we're going to
be jumping into
even bigger things almost immediately
right so we have
the revolutionary army and sabo
and the world government i mean caribou
is here in wano that should lead you to
fishman island and to shihoshi
again lead you to that part of the one
piece um worlds
and so you know it's very
reasonable for me for us to go from
fourth
throat poneglyph i think that we need to
at least
visit elbaf that's been set up king loki
um then we have the adventure to rafale
how
does this all still tie together in a
way that makes sense i think a lot of
people believe like it's gonna be
it should be a continuous journey right
so
luffy traveling the grand line the whole
adventure
aspect of it so maybe that part that
i mean maybe we're just right now that
close to the end of
you know he says the greatest part of
the adventure i assume that that's
raftel i assume that that's
finding the various islands the grand
adventure the romance dawn
um and i mean something like that isn't
impossible right because again
between kaido and big mom and the strats
right now we have three road poneglass
all you need is one more whatever that
is it might not take too long to find
and then
you know where raftel is um and i mean
i've always kind of thought that there
was going to be two major battles left
right the battle for raftel i guess
and then the final battle but maybe
maybe it's not
it's not in that way you know maybe it's
it's the adventure aspect of it
is doesn't culminate in a climactic 100
page arc
or 100 chapter arc and then instead what
we see is that sort of combines
with what we learned from that point and
then then onward but um
right yeah i mean i'm excited oh that's
super exciting
um i want to ask you another question jb
i'm just quickly gonna
like since we're kindly enough getting
getting uh some super chats
in uh welcome toby as a member i'm like
i'm super blown away i did not expect
so many people to become members but
much appreciated
um john d mann is asking could momo be
the
other sovereign instead of luffy i do
feel there's
i would i would want to put that
question up a bit later
please remind me if i forget to ask it
and uh toby is saying love your videos
looking forward for future videos and
live streams
much appreciated uh thank you for your
donation
and what i wanted to ask you jb and like
also you jay of course
is do you guys feel do you you expect
one piece after raftel especially do you
feel like
it's gonna be just like as we've known
it so far but just a step
more or do you expect that there will be
some type of like we talked about this
before will there be some sort of twist
that will
change the view we have of the one piece
world as such
completely basically like an attack on
titan
i'll let joe i'll let jb go first i mean
i i kind of brought this up earlier
right
that in the past you know the world
government actually exists
did i freeze before by the way no i
think it was oh no you're good
okay anyway sorry brain scatterbrained
um
uh but it's like did the does the world
government actually exist in order to
protect the world right i think that
right now we don't have that impression
right the world government has a source
of all evil
during the void century they were the
bad guys and they were for racism
and um they wanted to conquer the world
and subjugate everybody
but it would be very interesting turn of
events totally unexpected to
i think most people if you know maybe
not now but in the past from their onset
their creation and some of their central
values were actually positive and they
fought
the evil pirates that would be one way
in which you could turn that
or the only way that i can really think
of off the top of my head and i mean you
can see
kind of little things surrounding this
like for instance there's some
i guess uh gentle mannerisms for i'm
sama as he sort of
you know with the butterfly and then
what the goris as well
um they say some things they obviously
do a lot of evil stuff
but it's like this is like a general you
know world view question as well of like
what would you do
how far would you be willing to go in
order to create
a utopia right it's like for instance
reading kingdom right
um this is totally phrased in the
opposite way in kingdoms
you know the the the emperor or the king
um and you know they're they're fighting
to essentially subjugate and conquer
the rest of china and kingdom through
warfare through death
right um and so you know it's like you
could turn that story on its head and
they're like
you know the evil empire trying but then
you know from the standpoint of that
story it's like no we're bringing
china together so that there can be
peace right
and so you could see the same thing for
the world government right i think
that's a really interesting point i'm
just
wondering like i do i could definitely i
would agree with you there is that i
could see oda pulling a twist like that
i just wonder if like
based on the underlying like subtext on
the moral message that oda has
delivered in one piece so far i wonder
if
he would go in the direction of oh no
like the world government was actually
the good
guys i i could see a twist in the sense
of oda going like oh
the the world government sees itself as
the good people but in the end like
people like luffy will
obviously stay the morally right thing
yeah
yeah it's it's interesting right because
i mean you could you could have like so
there's two different kinds of pirates
from the original one shot
um there's peace main pirates which is
like your luffy and then there's morgan
ears which is your blackbeard
um so there's two distinctly different
kinds of pirates and so we assumed joy
boy and roger were piece
main pirates and so you know we know
after roger read
the rio poneglyph and the true history
he laughed
and you know like you know it's like i
could see
pirates such as luffy playing a more um
independent role in sort of all this
politics
where they just you know they're they're
the constant for
force of justice essentially sort of
keeping both sides in check
sort of fighting evil you know whenever
they see it at all costs or
you know whatever and then the other two
factions are
you know maybe particularly the world
government is
not as hard-lined as that whereas they
started off with these sort of
objectives and then they were heavily
corrupted
afterwards or went too far in order to
bring about peace or something like that
and so from that standpoint then you
could still see
pirates such as luffy being held up
above everybody else
thematically now joy boy there was
something that i mentioned between the
comparison of luffy
and roger and kind of the roles they
have as pirates now do you believe
dragon
and his possible future relationship
with luffy could engineer luffy to
actually be an opposing force towards
the world government
instead of more of an independent force
you know i don't really see dragon
having that kind of influence on luffy i
you know despite luffy being an idiot
he's also a free thinker you know he
experiences things and he learns in that
way
and so i think the whole purpose of the
journey i mean you see it
you know in small doses throughout the
course of the story at various points in
time where
luffy sees something that's wrong and i
do think that he takes this
in and he's learning steadily from it so
like
you know annie's lobby and and robin was
captured and the events in dressrosa and
the events in alabasta
sort of taken all this information in um
so i don't think it requires dragon
to turn luffy against the world
government what i think that's it's
going to be is going to be
his friends essentially the people that
he's
you know them being in danger you know
something like vivi
i think vivi's fate is questionable at
this moment what's going to happen
with her and so it's it's things like
that that's you know it's the enemy is
going to become clear
to luffy at some point in time i mean
even robin or
it could be that reading the true
history and the events in the past has
some effect on luffy as well
potentially so i actually agree with a
hundred percent with what you said about
luffy being much more of a
free thinker in that dragon you did
change loopy's my
dragon wouldn't um change his mind per
se but there could be
an instance where luffy and dragon meet
dragon
explains to luffy why he does the the
things he does and you know luffy and
his carefree man be like oh yeah that's
cool whatever
and you know there's like some sort of
relationship that is built there
and then the motivation that luffy
normally takes is if his friends are in
danger like you mentioned
what if a dragon tries to you know
execute his plan as a result
and he is either killed captured or
compromised in some way
that would give luffy the ample
motivation to actually
um counter the world government how
would you
or sabo exactly sabo is part of the
revolutionaries as well right exactly
right i i would vote for sabo before
dragon
you know i i'm kind of curious as to the
role of um the revolutionaries in the
story or like
how oda sees them um i mean we i think
we all believe right luffy is the hero
of the story at the end of the day what
he stands for is going to be ultimately
what's right
and so with that being said um luffy
didn't go out to become a revolutionary
no he's not
i'm a pirate yes um so i kind of you
know
we'll obviously see but i think that
there's going to end up being
something that the revolutionary army is
doing
wrong or oda was going to paint in that
way like dragon
again right it is he believes in what
he's his ideology at some point has to
differ from luffy's i also believe that
right right exactly
exactly and so as far as this makes
sense to me as of
right now is that maybe dragon is too
willing to
sacrifice in order to see his future and
i think that that's
where luffy is going to diverge as luffy
isn't willing to sacrifice it's
it's like it's uh the the trope of of
hope
you know this there's always a better
solution yeah and i think that luffy is
going to find that better solution even
greater than anything that dragon has in
mind i think dragon you know he wants to
tear down the world government
and i'm not certain by the end of the
story the world government needs to be
destroyed or at least the marines i
think the marines as an organization
still exists
um and i think that bringing together
various countries
conceptually without corruption isn't a
terrible idea as well
you know if you can eliminate the
celestial dragons and outside forces and
people trying to take advantage of the
system
so whereas dragon might want to take
down the whole system
i would be would change the heart
of the world i can see that i'm quickly
going to jump in one second because i
like i i appreciate much like i i've
never had to stream with like a thousand
five hundred people so i'm a bit
i'm learning as we're going um thank you
so much for
nate johnson for becoming a member and
um
cup is saying i missed two super chats
but i think i saw both of them
one was the one asking for momo
and the other one was uh appreciating
the the live stream so maybe i cut out
at the moment but i
i did acknowledge that so much
appreciated thank you very much
um yeah i i'm very happy you enjoy
the videos and the streams and luvish is
also saying always wanted to sit down
with you guys and simply talk
listen to you talk about one piece this
is like a wish come true
super happy to see the channel grow
shout out to jd and jb
thanks for thank you for this so i can
just thank you for the super chat and i
can just forward this thanks a lot for
sitting down with me guys discussing
this
this was like a very spontaneous idea
obviously um so much appreciated that
the two of you are hanging out with me
one thing i would be interested like to
hear your thoughts on because like
the idea recently with the odin
flashback i'm tying a little bit into
what you guys just said
um we we learned about like this kind of
like
prophesy like this prophet prophecy
aspect added to the story with uh joy
boy
and like the com the renewed coming of
joy boy right
i wonder do you personally see oda going
in the direction
like more of luffy being the chosen one
or do you see it rather in the direction
of going that luffy is like because this
is how i personally took it
um a bunch in the story that oda's
basically saying luffy is the person
defying destiny because will
beats destiny and like will beats
anything really
like wilby's physical power will beats
destiny how how do you
see that role in the story
i mean that's a critical question right
yeah this is one that is um
i would say personally i'm very torn on
uh because
this you know whether you enjoy this or
not i think comes down to maybe your
personal values and beliefs
right um you know do i
you know i i don't want to get into how
you know
all of that but um you know i don't like
the idea of
a chosen one i do love the idea of you
know
overcoming destiny personally um
however oda might not agree with that
many
people don't many people believe in
destiny and
and will and i've talked about this from
a buddhist standpoint as well
which oda may be buddhist or shinto
buddhist or you know whatever however
you want to though i do believe
like i'm definitely not a buddhist
myself but like as someone who
does who like is into meditation and
like
i am interested in like these uh
buddhist teachings and i
would believe that buddhism is as a
religion relatively
separate from destiny i would say the
way i've
read and learned about it so far
yeah so for buddhists your ultimate goal
and your ultimate destiny really as
as a existence as a soul as a
is to become enlightened to become a
buddha
that's the end goal right that'll
eventually i think theoretically happen
for everybody and then enlightenment as
i understand it and please correct me
again if i'm wrong here
but as i interpret it um enlightenment
is basically the state in which i
meditate
to the degree which in like its core
essence is like
separate from all the gods and like the
folklore around it like in its most
core form ultimately this is this is so
strange for people of western culture
culture but you lose yourself because
you lose
you lose all self it's it's more about
yeah like
it's basically what mindfulness is right
like you want to
ex you want to experience consciousness
as it is and since consciousness
entails everything like pain thoughts
feelings that is the state you want to
enjoy
exactly it's it's like it's like a state
of nothingness which is so
it's so counter to a lot of western
philosophies and i mean we've talked
about this before with mihawk
and and zorro mihawk probably being
christian
and zoro being buddhist the buddhist
idea is essentially mihawk never becomes
enlightened
because he gets stuck in the state of
being a god
yeah which is ultimate pleasure it's
heaven essentially but there's
for the buddhists there's a state out
like above yeah
enlightenment because heaven is not
eternal for them it it is
it is uh you know it's momentary
comparatively
right so anyway all that's really
interesting but you know it's like with
this whole joy boy situation from a
buddhist standpoint is
um reincarnation they believe in
reincarnation so
everybody who exists today everything
that exists today essentially has a soul
or spirit
and particularly in people and animals
these are you know you
all have the spirits of somebody who
lived or something that lived beforehand
right and so then joy boy being luffy
makes a lot of sense now whether that's
you know there's this ultimate destiny
or
or fate that he's going to change the
world and that's something that can't be
changed
that's so far over my head that i would
like to have a more
you know stronger opinion on that or not
it's just it's it's a question i'm like
that's one of the things that i'm really
waiting for for oda to give an answer
for a suggestion for in some kind of
thing i don't think it's gonna be
something crazy where he's like you know
pours it down our throat but
it might be an underlying theme but like
i feel like like sorry
sorry jay um i'm just gonna yeah just
cut in like for a second there because i
do feel i'm not sure if it's gonna be
just a random theme
i do believe like every every good story
at least
does carry the author's worldview right
like the
with his story the author is gonna wants
to make a deeper point about what he
thinks about the world whether that's a
good point or a bad point or
if it's like just a statement or how we
should live but there's like some
philosophy
about the world right as he sees it and
so i do believe that this question about
like
what luffy's journey and like role
actually is is it bound to destiny or is
it about defying destiny i do
believe that that will be one of the
major messages
in the story actually i believe yeah i
mean i mean
it's so interesting i mean we talk about
this buddhist thing forever it's like
you know there's a prevalent theme
within one piece that it's okay if you
die
you know that's like the ds they smile
before death they don't care you know
they embrace it
why because of buddhist teachings
because of reincarnation
you know you live your life the fullest
that you possibly can
every day you do the very best that you
that you can
you congress of it you treat everybody
well um and then
you know if you die you die and then you
come back and you again
repeat the process until you know you
have experienced enough about the world
about yourself
um in order to enlighten uh so uh
i forgot where i was going with this but
you know it's like
it's such an interesting conversation so
i
so i think if i'm trying to understand
what
you're alluding to with luffy being joy
boy and then the notion of
buddhism and reincarnation that there
could be a case where luffy is the joy
boy and there could be
um the option of destiny being imposed
on luffy but as a result
it could be a case where luffy is joy
boy and his destiny might be to save the
world but he also has the ability to
make his own choice
right based on his own motivations as
well so much that would be interesting
if at the end of the story there is like
the big moral decision right and like
luffy's and like luffy as the chosen one
might have to
might basically based on his destiny
only have the one decision to like i
don't know whatever it be like sacrifice
the few
like the few for the many or something
and since he's
also the question of inherited will as
well exactly
your will has a certain amount of power
coming out tomorrow actually
yeah and it i think it's it's all about
how you use that will that you've
inherited because you may not have the
same goals as the one who
same goes as the hill as the will that
you inherited but you use that same
drive and fervor that the previous
holder of that will had
and then you exact your own dream and
your own ideology with that same will if
that makes sense
it does make sense i'm not going to
comment on it as i said like i have i
have a big video coming
about big inherited will and the will of
d tomorrow
so i will not spoil too much but yeah i
would agree with you guys 100
and i also think um i'm sorry i also
think another good reference
to that is if you look at avatar the
last airbender now i
have you guys have you guys seen all of
that i don't want to spoil that at all
sadly not oh i can't spoil it still on
my list
but enjoyable i i think you know so you
remember how avatar ended right
so there that's a case of destiny where
there is a choice that had to be made
and instead of going with
the route that destiny tried to push him
into
the own that person's own answer was
found with
by their own will and do you think
that's the case where luffy could be in
that exact same position
but then based on his own um ideology of
freedom that he makes his own decision
and
whatever happens happens as a result of
that yeah i mean i i think so i think i
think there's so many
i this is this is one of those things
i'm really interested about there's a
lot of people that say things in the one
piece story of like
oh you know you got to do this or you
got to do that and i think i think
it's not going to be like that at all i
think that there's that luffy
is going to make his own decision like
for instance i think a lot of people
have the impression right
he's going to read the poneglyphs and
the polyglyphs are going to tell him
what to do oh i don't think so i think i
think that he's going to read the poem
gloves they might suggest an idea or
plan
but you know luffy doesn't follow plans
um or something
also sees that like they they do tell
what happened
and they're like well we couldn't
overcome this
good luck trying to figure it out
yourself kind of
right and then roger laughs and that's
something that just intuitively makes a
lot of sense
exactly no i would agree uh quick
intermesso uh once again we got
a donation 20 bucks with a super sticker
thank you very much
um nice super sticker i guess
all i can say appreciate it and we one
more one
new member also appreciate it thank you
very much um if if it's okay for the two
of you i would like
wrap this up in in like five to ten
minutes so i would say that
maybe once again for those of you who
are late or just
joined the stream we're actually like
this is not a clickbait video actually
i try to keep my integrity
there is actually uh leaks from the new
sbs where
oda has been asked by a fan whether he's
serious about ending one piece in five
years and his answer was in summary
that he plans on ending a story about
luffy becoming pirate king in five years
but after that there will be a
basically different story about luffy
chain or a big war happening
and luffy changing the world basically
and like that's going to be a separate
story and like he doesn't count that
into the five years
so that's thank you cup for posting it
also um so that's that's what we're
talking about
maybe to wrap this up um like first of
all i enjoyed this a lot i could do this
probably for four hours with the two of
you we should definitely repeat this at
some point
maybe as some closing thoughts um
what are your biggest or what is
something you
definitely feel now that we got the time
for it that you would love to see happen
in the story whether it be an arc or
a character development or whatever it
is like one thing if you have to pick
what you want to see
uh i guess i'll go um me personally
and i am fully fully invested on this
avoid century flashback art fully
invested
because now that i know for a fact that
oda plans to go way beyond luffy's
individual adventure if we get a voice
entry flashback where we get it's more
about the politics than the actual
action and the clashes of philosophy and
um the secrets and the secrets about say
like king's race or
the importance of race within the one
piece world before the world government
was truly established
these are all things that i would
literally be forming at the mouth to
read every chapter like i think that
would be
so it would one piece is already like
the most unique manga out there but if
we get a voice entry flashback where
it's strictly politics and philosophy
i think i would be in heaven and the
amount of videos i would just make on
each chapter alone
would probably they'd have probably have
to ban me off youtube for uploading too
much content because
there's so many things i would just want
to talk about so if there's anything i
want
out of this news is a voice entry
flashback card that's oh i want that so
much
like oh my goodness that's it
that's really it for me i would i would
subscribe to that
jb what about you i mean that's a
difficult question to ask i'm looking
forward to it all
like like everything from here on is a
big yes for me
like exclamation point i mean uh
specifically thinking about one thing
that i've always been excited for is
sort of the
the where oda intends to take the
fishman conflict
right i think that has a very very very
high potential to make me cry like
you know like it's um the way that i
throw it down it's it's like what
one of the main things that i know is
going to hit or shanks as well jinx is
another good one
um but you know it's like it's like
there was a theory that i had a long
time ago which is essentially that
uh the fisherman's story is going to
[Music]
uh mimic but reverse what happened in
our long park
so we see park it was the fishmen were
the bad guys and the nami sort of
played the dutiful role of working with
the bad guys
in order to bring peace to her people
the humans
yes and so the fishermen are doing that
right now otohime has been trying to do
that
right um they're trying to work with the
bad guys the government the humans
um in order to find peace for their
people
um and in arlon park it didn't go well
uh for nami you know uh where she she
was like i needed
one 1 million or 100 million berries and
then
my people are free and then she got
really close and then arlung was like
nope
you know you you like i i'm stealing all
your money and you start from zero
and i fully 100 percent expect the thing
the same thing to occur again but again
reversed
where the fishmen are now part of the
reverie uh they feel like they're close
to some sort of
lasting peace and resolution be able to
live with everyone else
and accomplish their dreams and
something is going to happen to take
that away from them
and i think that's probably going to
involve shira hoshi at the very least
because of ancient weapon i think that
that's
fairly straightforward and then what you
get after theirs you get really powerful
i mean even talking about it right now
like makes me want to tear up a little
bit
of like frustration right because you
work so hard
and then you get reset back to zero and
so what happened in arlong park
was finally the people the humans gave
up
and they went on a death march they were
like well we know we're going to die
we're going to lose we're not strong
enough but we would rather die
than you know continue trying to be part
of the system
yeah and so i kind of see the same thing
happening again the
fishman get betrayed one more time and
it's the final straw
and it's like okay all right it's war
civil war if we die we die
yep um and that's you know well it
speaks for itself
for sure i i really like that thought um
i'm not sure i see it 100
going down or like i mean i know like
you're not saying that's 100 what's
gonna happen but like
i i still belie like i'm not sure if the
fishman will go completely
or depends on how you mean it but like i
still see them siding with luffy to a
certain extent
you know but to see what ended up
happening was the people went to go
fight arlong
in a self-sacrificial move and then he
stopped he stopped him you usopp you had
that epic
panel with like usopp and zuro and sanji
and they're like nah
right okay got this so you know
no good points i think and i personally
do believe in general like recently
since i've been like going
like through the arcs and like doing
these scene analyses like looking back
at a lot of them like i talked
about with uh jd earlier like drum
island for instance
um is so much more important on a reread
in terms of inherited will and the will
of d
and then um thriller bark has been
getting a lot
more context recently and then fishman
island i feel like is also one of the
arcs that like will be so much more
relevant that people will give it credit
for
so i do agree 100 um thank you so much
again for the donation
manuel cruz jr trafalgar waterloo didn't
smile when he thought he was going to
die
and luffy saved him from doflamingo that
is a good observation
um but yeah i
i'm not sure any quick thoughts on that
um no not really not really but it's a
good observation i would say thanks so
much for
for that um insight and also
i think if it's cool with you guys i
would slowly call it an end here i think
two hours is a good point my voice is
already
kind of gone so um
let's let's slowly wrap this up in case
so first of all thank you very much to
the two of you for dropping by it was a
real pleasure jb
we've talked like a lot on twitter but
like really good
talking in person it's a lot more fluent
to exchange ideas like this i think
yeah also jd of course like i
i always love having you on and talking
with you so thanks so much for
doing this spontaneously with me of
course um for the people in the chat
yeah like in case
you are not subscribed or at least
haven't checked out the content of these
uh
two wonderful people that are
accompanying me um the links
will be in the description of course of
this video so make sure to check both of
them out
and if you like their content also
subscribe and you know show them some
love
i think both of them like jb is
definitely pretty much the only one
piece youtuber i watch regularly
and uh jd i know does
a lot of great content and especially
has probably one of the best
personalities
i think in the one piece community so i
think both of them definitely
worth giving a shot otherwise than that
yeah thank you so much to all the new
members i did
definitely not plan on this so this was
very spontaneous but i much appreciate
all the support and all the love thank
you for all the super chats
and otherwise yeah big news um i think
we're all excited
for all the videos that are about to
come on this i'm definitely excited to
see both of your videos on this
and any last words from your site
the only thing i would have to say is uh
you need to watch avatar the last
airbender 100
i will you you are if you are
a big fan of meditation and does the
ideology of buddhism
the fact that you haven't watched avatar
is a crime i'm just going to say
it's peak fiction so definitely check
that out for sure i will do that
i will invite the both of you once i'm
done
for a discussion i could talk about
avatar forever so please by all means
much appreciated um any less words jb
i mean i don't have anything to say i
just appreciate you having me on who's
spontaneous i still haven't read all the
sbs but it's okay
i'm very happy you you joined i got you
on here and uh yeah i'm i'm very excited
about your theories on this so i feel
like this
uh opens up a lot of space for things to
happen
good night guys was a pleasure yeah
really
spontaneous weird stream with a lot of
people in here so good experience i hope
you have a great week
have a great uh yeah had a